today on stick to football it's Monday
and that means it is mock draft Monday
time Matt Melo and Connor check us out
on bleach reports YouTube or listen to
us wherever you get your podcast guys
less than a month to the NFL Draft so
today's mock will be what we would do as
general managers of the top 32 picks but
here's where we're gonna start the show
today guys the rosters for the B are
goats greatest of all greatest of all
time stimulation have been announced and
I just want to take another lap because
there's no way the 49ers lose this thing
no way at all they did pick Joe Montana
as a starter we all know he's gonna get
hurt in the first quarter and Steve
Young is gonna come in and save the day
but Jerry Rice tío John Taylor it steams
on unbeatable know I don't know I said
the Steelers and then they took it to
like a Twitter vote and they put Ben
Roethlisberger as a starting quarterback
I think Connor was probably right when
he said the Cowboys the offensive line
is just gonna be unstoppable does that
matter and Madden I think it does when
you have Emmitt Smith running behind you
with I mean Tony Dorsett and Zeke yeah
yeah and Herschel Walker like yeah
that's a good point
and you got to think compiled the
computer plays where they just sit in
the pocket and wait all day bright yeah
and if you have that stamina turned on
where players are actually getting tired
like just run the ball all day behind
Zack Martin Larry Allen Travis Frederick
like it's not bad and then you have your
guy probably Charles Haley down here
he's neither actually huh there you go
yep I don't know I'm looking through
these rosters the Broncos were gonna be
very tough to beat as well I was gonna
say I'm glad you said that Melo I looked
at the Broncos and I was like man you
kind of forget that they're gonna boost
up Elway because he was phenomenal he
can move he could throw the ball down
the field he's kind of like I guess the
closest thing in old Madden would have
to mahomes where you can get him outside
the pocket and just launch the ball and
they're gonna be playing each other in
the first round me and Matt are actually
gonna be helping broadcast that game
Tuesday night if you want to ask drew
out questions do whatever you want to do
we'll be in there but their defense is
ridiculous on so many levels so I think
the Broncos are one of the sneakier
teams as well and like Connor said you
can watch these games on the bleacher
report twitch channel over the next two
weeks starting March 30th that's today
to April 13th every
night from 7 to 11 p.m. Eastern Time
these games will be going off with the
championship taking place on April 13th
for the the greatest of all time I don't
know if we're handing out trophies for
this thing or not but we probably should
be but like Connor said you'll see us in
there every now and then doing our thing
and our thing mostly this time of year
normally would be the NFL Draft thanks
to our terrible person Cove at 19
there's everything is shut down right
now no player interviews nope other than
on skype no player visits no physicals
and that has really changed the
landscape of how teams were preparing
for the draft and because of that guys
the the only real nugget I have to drop
for you this Monday morning is I'm
hearing multiple teams prefer Justin
Herbert to Alabama's to Otunga by Loeb
because of injuries and the unknowns and
I was actually talking to a high-level
team exec yesterday and he said you know
in a normal year you could honestly make
the argument to it should be the number
two overall pick and maybe the number
one overall pick but because you're
taking a third party's word for it when
it comes to his medicals at this point
in time that teams are just going to be
a little bit hesitant and because of
that this guy and other other team
officials as well have told me don't be
surprised if Justin Harbor is the second
quarterback picked because there are no
questions about injuries when it comes
to his evaluation I think that's a
terrible take the insider you're talking
to that is just dumb I'm sorry you do
not take Justin Herbert over to a if any
teams are listening to this right now
like just take to it I would rather take
my chance of a hip than a guy that's
gonna throw 25 interceptions a year but
we have this happen every year I know
like don't overthink it it's so easy to
is good getting behind it offensive line
that's also good and keep him healthy I
think that's it that's all you have to
do that's exactly how I feel I would
take the good quarterback that has
injury risk over the bad one I'm sorry I
know it's harsh to sit here and call
Justin Herbert bad but I think if you
put him on an NFL field right now he
would be in the bottom tier and I'm just
not a big believer in developing him and
to be this top 10 kind of guy that he's
gonna be valued at when he goes as a top
five top ten pick in this draft so I
totally see it Matt and believe it
because I think teams do this
every single year and I think it would
be a colossal mistake oh yeah last year
we saw Daniel jones be the second
quarterback drafted and a top-10 pick
when I none of us had him greater that
highly the year before that we saw Baker
Mayfield who was my number four
quarterback be the number one pick in
the first quarterback selected so we do
see teams fall in love for odd reasons
but I think this is something notable to
address is that we are in an
unprecedented time when it comes to
draft preparation I mean when it comes
the entire world none of us have ever
seen anything like what's going on daily
just turn on the news it's it's a scary
movie every day and because of the
concerns of injury I would not be
shocked if the Miami Dolphins say you
know what are our other quarterbacks are
Josh Rosen and Ryan Fitzpatrick we need
somebody who could play right now now if
you're the LA Charger she have Tyrod
Taylor you have Easton stick you're okay
you feel like you can roll out there for
2020 with one of those guys and be okay
but if you're the Dolphins and you've
kind of backed yourself into a corner of
Nene guy who can get on the field right
now I could see them not saying I would
do it and you'll you'll hear that when
we get her to our mock draft but I would
not be shocked if if that is the case
where Justin Herbert had a great senior
Bowl I'm a great Rose Bowl great senior
bowl great combine and then the whole
world shuts down and you have this six
foot six 240 pound quarterback with a
rocket right arm and no injuries it it's
at least understandable the teams would
fall for that now I'm saying I would but
do you think that this could be a move
to get to it a drop though teams try to
put out information all the time to get
football and you know maybe convince a
team like the Dolphins like everybody
else is saying that they like Justin
Herbert maybe we should do some more
work and then late in this process you
fall in love with Justin Herbert and all
along you should have taken - uh yeah
I'm Jeff yeah I mean I've been like -
this time of year multiple times I've
I've told you guys stories over the
years or it definitely happens and this
could be one of those cases but this
isn't just one team saying hey I think
Justin Herbers gonna go over to it this
is a lot of people believe this right
now do you also think Matt there's
something to be said about a team
getting out in front of the possibility
that say the Chargers jump Miami right
the Chargers go to three or four they
take to Miami sits there five and goes
you know what we like Justin Herbert we
liked to a more
but we like Justin Herbert we'll take
him at five and he's our franchise guy
going forward you can kind of spin it
towards the public after saying hey
Herbert was our guy all along that's why
we didn't really you know push too hard
to get a trade done we felt like we can
get him at fun without a doubt and I can
actually tell you guys an instance where
this happened in 2018 when the Jets had
the number three overall pick you could
talk to multiple people in that building
and hear that they liked a different
quarterback and I do believe that's what
was happening they were almost field
testing what the reaction would be to
certain quarterbacks but then there were
there were elements of the the team that
said hey the quarterback coach liked
Josh Allen that's who he wanted people
in the front office wanted Sam Darnell
there were area Scouts who won a Baker
Mayfield so I think it also goes to like
who do you talk to because when you're
in a position where there might be
multiple quarterbacks on the board like
it 14 were to trade up you're gonna get
different factions that say no no we
want to trade up for this guy it's not
always you know Brent beech telling Andy
Reed two years before that we're gonna
draft Patrick mahomes it doesn't always
it's not always that that you know
together I don't know it just it still
seems fishy to me
if if I'm taking either one of these
guys like I just think - even with the
injuries his head and shoulders above
Herbert and maybe I like to it way too
much but I I think that he throws with
accuracy and the only question is is he
healthy and so far he's looked healthy I
know that he's had the injuries in
college but man I just I think there's a
big difference when you look at two
overs Justin Herbert
oh it's colossal I mean I have to a
fourth overall right now and I'll have
to look for Herbert I have Herbert
somewhere in the second round last time
I looked I mean I like Jordan love over
Justin Herbert right now but I just
think the NFL views him extremely
extremely different right now yeah and
again not saying it's right but we have
seen it happen where a guy like Justin
Herbert does get valuable teams
overthink it and I can't sit here and
pretend like I'm always right either
yeah I mean I had Jarret Stidham as my
number one quarterback last year I liked
Mason Rudolph a lot how most said Mason
Ramsey which I still like Mike's Ramsey
a lot Mason Rudolph though and not so
proud of that one anymore so I mean I
haven't been wrong on quarterbacks
before yeah I just I wouldn't take
Justin Herbert in the top five of this
draft not with
sitting right there alright let's take a
break and find out who we would take in
this draft wits our mock draft of what
we would do as general managers we'll be
back right after this
it is mock draft Monday time we get a
couple more of these before the NFL
Draft actually gets here April 23rd set
to kick off from points unknown Roger
Goodell is living room it's probably
where we will be and we don't know where
we will be but we will be covering the
draft for you that part is guaranteed
and mellow you get the honors today with
the first pick in the draft you were on
the clock with these Cincinnati bang it
with the Cincinnati Bengals I think that
they're in obvious position to take a
quarterback and this isn't just sticking
to the old boring oh what do we think is
gonna happen
I do think that the Bengals should take
jobber I think bringing him back to Ohio
building that fan base and actually
proving that yeah we can win and getting
him on the field early with guys like AJ
Green and Joe Mixon that's the move to
make I really like to I just kind of
went on a little rant about him but I
think the pick here for the Bengals has
to be Joe burrow I know he had one great
year and I'll tell you that makes me
nervous
you go back and you look at the number
one quarterbacks taken in every draft
doesn't correlate to success always
we're seeing a lot of young quarterbacks
who were taking number one overall
struggle and some of them even getting
replaced like Jameis Winston now so I
think the pick has to be Joe burrow he's
just he's too good it fits the need I'll
go with borough number one we talked
about him so much and she's like oh but
burdens of angles you've been doing this
a couple years where would he rank for
you in terms of quarterbacks you've
evaluated probably not in the top five
really I like Sam darn old a lot more
than him I guess he would probably be in
the top five probably like three maybe
Connor where would he be for you that's
a great question
um I don't know I would have to really
comb through and see because 2018 I
obviously like to Rosen and Baker a lot
I had them in the top ten and Rosen has
flopped and Baker were kind of in
wait-and-see mode and then I had it as
Lamar at 3:00 and then darn 'old four
and Lamar has been amazing in a good
situation and Arnold's been up and down
I liked those top four like a lot a real
lot I don't know I guess I would put
borough
right in the middle there and that's
really tricky I'd really have to comb
through because I don't know I liked
Watson a lot too Watson was my top
quarterback and I think my number two
overall player that year so I wouldn't
have him over Watson that is tricky
that's kind of what I was thinking too
that's kind of what I consider like the
first draft with my bad Pat mahomes take
but I like knots and a lot I still like
darn 'old more than Watson so probably
I'd Arnold Watson and then borough but
me and I I'm still not sold on him like
I honestly wouldn't be surprised if Joe
borough ends up being a bust I like the
kid I want to root for him but having
all that success with about nine
offensive NFL players on your roster an
offensive coordinator that came in and
just revamped your offense there was a
lot going on there that led to his
success that he didn't have in his
junior year this guy lost his job I mean
it was an open competition to Haskins at
Ohio State forced him to LS you know
whatever yeah he lost his job they had
an open competition all spring and
Dewayne Haskins beat him out
Dwayne Haskins a guy who might even get
replaced by the Redskins after one year
so there are a lot of question marks I
don't think Joe burrow is this perfect
Heisman Trophy winning national
championship quarterback that we want
him to be I've compared him before to
Baker Mayfield Baker Mayfield is not
finding success in the NFL and he has
all the tools to do it I think if they
get an offensive line maybe that changes
things but I don't view Joe burrow is
like a perfect quarterback prospect well
that's why this shows fun because I have
given him the second highest quarterback
grade every I have Andrew Luck and I
have Joe Barnes here I'm dead serious I
we changed our grading scale this year I
gave him a 96 overall all right well
there's that I guess that's why I didn't
well I don't want to give you my opinion
I want to hear your guys know I'm not
that low I mean I compared him to Matt
Ryan who has been a really good NFL
quarterback for a while now but Matt
Ryan's never a guy that you sit there
and put on the platform that you have
Brady Brees Russ obviously Pat now you
know I think he's a good I think burrow
can easily be that top 12 quarterback
top 10 quarterback I'm not in the you
know in the view that he will be the
best quarterback in the league
one day well I think if you're coming to
the NFL with Patrick my home Asilomar
Jackson and Russell Wilson like you're I
can't see him being better than those
guys right you know I don't think I'll
be a top five not gonna happen yeah it's
just where you're coming in but as
approximate I was very low on the homes
and one thing that I've learned from
that is and we talked about this a ton
on here situation matters so much
because if my home's been drafted by the
Browns so I I think it takes him a lot
longer to get to this level and maybe he
flames out before he gets to this level
so I think situation matters Joe burrow
is going to a good one in my opinion as
far as the players around him but I know
we talked so much about that pick it's
been set in stone for four months I just
wanted to take that conversation
somewhere differently and Conor you were
on the board now number two overall yeah
I'm about to flip the draft upside down
I think ultimately this guy does go to a
really good situation when it's all said
and done I think to has a very good
chance to be on the Chargers and that
would be great for him but number two to
the Redskins in this mock draft because
it's the what we would do mock draft I'm
taking tua and Melo alluded to it a lot
in the first segment tua is a great
player when healthy and with Washington
right now I don't know if they have a
great player at quarterback with Dwayne
Haskins last year I had him 18th overall
in what was let's be real guys not a
star-studded quarterback class I really
like Schuyler Murray I had him in the
top five and then that was it and then
with Haskins you look at it he was
somebody that you see the talent to
develop but Ron Rivera didn't come in
necessarily signing up saying hey I'm
here to develop Dwayne Haskins and maybe
you know maybe he will I don't think
they're gonna take to a when all is said
and done but I don't know how tied they
are long term to Haskins if things don't
work out this well this year you only
pick this high so many times guys I love
chase young I think he's the best player
in the draft but I look it too I have
him fourth overall I think he's a
phenomenal quarterback if he never got
her I'd have him over Jill burrow I
don't think it would even be that big of
a difficult decision for me when all is
said and done so for the Redskins it
stinks that they botched this with Trent
Williams because if you had Trent
Williams coming back at left tackle and
you could have you know taken some
offers to move on from Haskins and you
take to it you feel good about putting
him behind that offensive line
I think tua and Rivera
something you could build around for a
decade with a caveat that everyone talks
about can to us stay healthy but I'm
willing at number two to take the risk
because I think you could be a great
player in the NFL when I saw you put
this pic in to me it just comes down to
it's not that I don't like doing Haskins
it's not that I didn't like doing
Haskins I just like to a better and
that's that is a quarterback that
matters and I think the Cardinals proved
last year that you can do that you know
don't just sit there and say oh man we
took a quarterback let's keep rolling
out with this guy like if it's not
working go replace them especially if
you have a quarterback right there that
you can take like - I and I love chase
young - number one guy on my board
they've got some pretty damn good pass
rushers there in Washington that's not a
need for them at all no when you look at
the Redskins needs you would not say
edge rusher you would you would honestly
say left tackle it's the biggest one but
there's not a factor that you had taken
to overall but then would you would you
guys do what I did
oh yeah yeah that would have been my
pick as well I remember laughing at the
Cardinals though last year I mean I
you're gonna take a quarterback again
like hey you're gonna waste that pick
but I would and I would try to move on
from Haskins and try to get some picks
back I think you can probably find a
team that will give you a second rounder
find some teams that that really liked
him last year that still need a
quarterback go do it and I would take to
a number two overall IV calling New
England saying hey you want doing
Haskins yeah somebody take some although
we keep saying that I think knowing Ally
Sierra stead of all right I'm on the
board number three overall the Detroit
Lions thanks to my great friends Melo
and Connor chase young is still on the
board and if you are the Lions this is
the easiest pick that your franchise has
ever made chase Young is the best player
in this class I've seen people from the
great Mel Kiper - others say like what
you know he just wasn't that impressive
this year I don't know what the [ __ ] you
guys were watching he was incredibly
impressive every step of the way this
year national championship or excuse me
because well playoffs he's still
wrecking folks I mean he's still just
continually making huge place I love
chase young I think he is you know a
Khalil Mak Myles Garrett type guy he
might not be Nick Bosa against the run
but that's okay I think his first step
is better than what Nick Bosa showed
coming out of Ohio State
he's a technician he's gonna build a win
with speed with power with moves his
awareness is very good
and he just once he wants to be great
this guy who loves playing football
wants to be great if chase young bust it
will be one of the biggest surprises of
my career I agree with you completely I
love chase young I think he fits in any
scheme as well and I'm up again with the
Giants at number four looking at the
Giants team I think there's an obvious
need at tackle we know how gediman feels
about linebackers but for me Jeff accout
is sitting there and I think he's a
special corner and our listeners might
be wondering like I thought you loved
Isiah Simmons I do but I'm picking for a
defense that mainly runs a three-four
and I don't like Isiah Simmons in a
three-four defense I like him being able
to have that versatility he's not gonna
play edge rusher for you in that defense
he's not gonna play middle linebacker so
now your draft and a safety at number
four overall and you're sticking them in
a spot and saying alright your safety
now go play safety and I don't like that
so I'm not gonna doing with the Giants
I'm gonna take Jeff cooter who is gonna
be a real difference maker on this
defense I know that they have DeAndre
Baker Thorpe Award winner who played
okay at times last year they saying
signed James Bradbury but corners like
this don't come around very often and
that's why he's being drafted in the top
five of this draft so I'm going with
Jeff a COO to take away an entire side
of the field he's gonna be a great
corner from day one I get this is what
you would do not what Dave get Emil yeah
because they've got hate score not
anyone on the secondary this high yeah I
was gonna say and then you have you have
a really bad secondary turning into a
really good one him Bradbury you're
still developing DeAndre Baker that'd be
a hell of a trio a corner in a division
where guess what guys you're gonna need
it this year so number five the Miami
Dolphins no twoa on the board noburo on
the board I am NOT taking Justin Herbert
at five I'm sorry I'm sure the Dolphins
would in this scenario I'm taking Jedrek
wills guys have you looked at who's
starting four offensive and offensive
tackle both anybody else but I don't
even know how you're putting a rookie
quarterback back there and you could sit
here and say well they have eight
million draft picks I don't think picks
18 and on or getting you all these
starting tackles so for the Dolphins
here I feel like this is a win if you're
a Dolphins fan I know you're kicking the
can down the road for quarterback that's
not something you want to hear it stinks
but guess what you got a franchise left
or right tackle wherever you want
in Jedrek wills that can also get your
run game going which if you listen to
the rest of this mock draft that's gonna
matter a lot number six the Los Angeles
chargers Justin Herbert is on the board
Jordan Love is on the board
I'm not taking either of those guys
because I do not feel that they're
worthy of a top six pick in this draft
against what I would do I would roll
Tyrod Taylor out there I would sign Cam
Newton and I would go with Easton stick
as my backup that I'm developing there's
no way that I feel like Justin Herbert
especially 2020 it's a better
quarterback than what came in and her
Tyrod Taylor could be for you so I'm
gonna go with Isiah Simmons and this is
not a need at all but I do not care
because if I can put Isiah Simmons in
Derwin James on defense with Casey
Heyward and Chris Harris in Joey Bosa
and Melvin Ingram I really don't care
about anything else because that could
be the best defense in the NFL yeah III
think so in what him endure when James
together I would love to see how they
play with one another they may in
defense all right having those two cuz
Derwin James did so much freedom at
linebacker as well and then Isiah
Simmons can do so much a safety it would
make things very difficult for everybody
in the AFC number seven overall the
Carolina Panthers again this is what I
would do and I'm looking at the board I
really like Jedrek Wilson and if he were
sitting there I would take you if Isiah
Simmons were sitting there I would take
him I don't love the quarterbacks either
so I'm not going that route they have
Teddy Bridgewater in-house I think that
they're gonna move on with him for the
future I think that they really like him
there so I'm going to give him some
weapons because I still really like
Jerry Judy this was a guy that we had as
high as like the number two on some of
our boards I know I did there for a
while right behind Chase young I still
think he can be a huge difference maker
at receiver putting him in this offense
with Christian McCaffrey I think
eventually that the Panthers are gonna
have to realize we can't just do
everything he threw Christian McCaffrey
we need to get some targets on the
outside to even go with Robby Andersen
and more and you know Curtis Samuels
there's some very good talented
receivers there but when I'm looking at
the board know Jedrek wills knows I
Isaiah Simmons I'm gonna take Jerry Judy
and just say you know what we'll just
air it out if we can't block that long
we'll find guys who can get open quick
that would
the best group of skill players in the
NFL right there it's not even close I
mean you really pencil it in where you
have Christian McCaffrey at running back
DJ more and then Robbie Anderson on the
outside and you'd play Judy in the slot
and he would he would devour slot
corners Bower
it would be like Justin Jefferson and
that Joe Brady offense that's exactly
what it is he'd have so much space to
work with like you said mellow Teddy
gets the ball out quick in that
situation I like that a lot
eight the Arizona Cardinals this pic has
been happening in real mock drafts but
this is also the what we would do
version it's very easy
Tristan worse they need an offensive
lineman they need a guy that can either
play on the you know a tackle spot he
could play guard he's athletic he could
do everything you asked of him in this
offense to get the run game going to
give Kyler Murray more pass protection
so this is probably the easiest pick
I'll have to make in the mock trap
Tristan works the cargo and this is a
pick you hear a lot around the league
that could actually happen they they
really value him they need a right
tackle and he can play that we've seen
it plug and play at that spot I am up
here the Jacksonville Jaguars number
nine overall when I look at the Jaguars
to see a team with they have a ton of
needs across the board but where's the
direction of this team going they've
traded away some of their best players
they've tried to retool at other
positions if I'm the general manager of
the Jacksonville Jaguars guys I'm going
corner CJ Henderson I believe can shut
down one side of the field I don't value
defensive tackle this high for a Derrick
brown or Javon Kinlaw especially for a
team that has two first-round picks I
want to get a corner in a draft where
there's just in my opinion there are two
good corners and then there's a drop-off
and the drop-off is pretty significant
so getting making sure that I get one of
the elite corners after trading away
Jalen Ramsey trading away AJ boy you got
to get somebody out there who can cover
and I'm a big CJ Henderson fan I thought
I was the biggest CJ Henderson fan on
this podcast but man you got a mile I
can draw I do too I like his length I
like a speed I think that plays at
corner anywhere number ten overall the
Cleveland Browns thank you guys for
letting me pick for the Browns I love
this I don't love a lot of the tackles
in this class I would think I'm in the
minority there I like wills a lot I
would have taken him very high in this
draft
I like Tristan works but he's not there
either so I'm going to pass on offensive
tackle I know that's a huge need for
the Browns but I'm not in love with guys
like Becton or Thomas or Jones or Austin
Jackson none of them I I'm not in love
with them but I do really like Derrick
Brown and I think that the Browns have
to find a way to start stopping guys
like Lamar Jackson it's going to be a
very big problem for them and I think
one way you can do that is with some
penetration up the middle stopping the
run game that the Ravens love so much
that the Steelers will probably try to
get back to so I'm taking Derek Brown to
just kind of shore up to the interior of
my defensive line and I mean the guy can
play a lot of different positions I know
he didn't test well it's a combine but
the tape is there and the tape tells me
that he can dominate the SEC which means
he can probably dominate in the AFC
North as well kinda this is just mellow
hating picker may feel the wanting him
to get hit it's like I'm a taker left
tackle and it works out in my favor
because that number 11 yeah Thank You
Melo at number 11 for the New York Jets
I get Andrew Thomas and Melo you brought
up that you like Jedrek wills you like
Tris and worse I think Andrew Thomas is
the third one for me I have these guys
really lumped together we're obviously
wills and Worth's are in their own crew
but I think Thomas is a plug-and-play
starter from day one and he's a big
upgrade over Jorge fan left tackle for
the New York Jets so Thomas is a guy
that gives you a lot of power in the run
game he's somebody that's a high IQ
player and pass protection I think he he
always understands this spacing he
always understands passing off stunts
are picking up stunts this would be a
really really big upgrade overall for
Sam Donald and for the New York Jets
this is a difficult decision to make
because you have C D lamb on the board
you can go get yourselves a number one
wide receiver but once again they could
not keep the quarterback upright last
year Andrew Thomas has done a really
good job of that for Jake from over the
last couple years and this also helps
levy on bail in the run game Connor
fewer the Jets GM like if you got the
job today right there like they fire
everyone you get the job right now
knowing what you know would you trade
Jamal Adams like with how poorly they've
executed you get 17 from Dallas that's
it
I know that's not realistic got like 17
and a you know couple day three picks I
wouldn't instead Matt I would trade for
Trent Williams and take C D lamb at
yeah that make they have they have the
second most cap space in the NFL right
now I would find a way to make it work
with Trent now I know what you're saying
though like an our philosophy on this
podcast almost nine out of ten times you
do trade Jamaal in that scenario because
I don't think the Jets are in a position
to win unfortunately with the head coach
they have where you capitalize on the
value right now for Jamaal Adams but man
I think it would just suck the life at
the little life left out of the team I
mean this is the closest they've had
since Revis left to a franchise player
yeah that's a good stuff it's it's tough
it's a really tough decision I don't
think it's that cut and dried and it's
tough that your best players are safety
you know like I love Jamal Adams well I
think he's one of the best safety some
football it's just not that important of
a position you know it'd be like your
best player being an offensive guard you
know like that's that's awesome like via
Quinta Nelson that's huge but he alone
is not gonna change the game that much
so you need you need other pieces so
that's the reason I bring that all right
number 12 the Las Vegas Raiders with
their first pick in this trap I'm gonna
go wide receiver because Henry rugs is
on the board and I think I said this on
the Friday show Jon Gruden has had to
watch Tyree kill twice a year for a
couple years now why not go get your own
version of that somebody who just
completely terrifies the defense even
when he doesn't get the ball how many
times the guy like that opens things up
for the tight end open things up for the
run game when you have dare Waller at
Titan who's a great great athlete when
you already have a couple other good
possession receivers when you have it
running back in Josh Jacobs who's a
do-it-all player someone who can stretch
the field vertically like Henry rug's
completely changes the framework of your
often so wide receiver I think is the
biggest need for this team I know a lot
of people would say why not CD lamb I
just think in this particular offense
Henry rug's is a difference maker and
honestly I have rugs and lamb graded
identically but when you have to you
have to break a tie I gave the
tiebreaker to Henry rugs as my number
two receiver was it the speed that did
it for you
it wasn't speed and that again I'm not
trying to trash CD lamb I liked him a
lot
we've praised him for months here my
concerns with CD lamb are I think he
might be a slot only guy at the next
level he has
run about three routes of Oklahoma and
he's never had to play against press
coverage and he's not that fast there's
just not I don't even mean the forty
time I just there's not a lot of juice
when he has to cut at the the routes Tim
there's not a lot of burst and explosion
I do worry about that a little bit where
he's he's a very fiscal receiver who's
also not that big how well is that gonna
translate well you're getting him at
number thirteen overall with San
Francisco 49ers because I absolutely
love CD and I would be fine with him in
that office I have all three of these
receivers lumped together I was picking
for the Panthers at seven overall and I
almost took C delay him over Jerry Judy
I really like these three receivers and
what they can do CD lamb I think he he
looks slow is why people say oh I don't
know if he has a speed I I think that he
does he came out ran a very good forty
he gets away from everybody watch the
Texas game again if you can I don't want
to five guys around him and they just
can't tackle him and he catches the ball
in a crowd there's just not much I
haven't seen him do and I think he plays
a lot bigger than he is I think he's six
to one ninety yeah
plays like he's 6-3 to ten I really like
CD lamb if my team needed a receiver I
mean I would have a hard time passing up
CD Liam just like Connor just said like
Jets at eleven I'm assuming you meant
with Jerry Judy on the board you still
would take CD lamb everytime exactly I
mean I really think he's gonna be a
special like probably a Pro Bowler in
his rookie year Wow depending on fit if
he goes to the 49ers at 13 overall CD
lamb will be a Pro Bowl or his rebellion
you know we had a meeting get cancelled
we have a little time to talk about this
with CD lamb I think if he goes
somewhere where he can run slants and
underneath routes he could be he could
be a Pro Bowler early on so fit does
matter if he goes somewhere where
they're gonna say hey you're our X
receiver and we're gonna ask you to
stretch the field and you're gonna have
to beat press coverage that's just not
who he is so if he goes to the Niners
where a lot of their routes are timing
based there underneath routes this is
still a West Coast offense with an
inside zone run scheme then I think CD
lamb could have a ton of success there
alright fourteen the Bucks another team
that still needs help at tackle
especially when you got Tom Brady back
there you got to keep him upright and
I'm gonna go with Makai Becton this is
the run-on tackles right here you know
the classic big four we've been calling
them for a while and I think with Becton
he's somebody that probably needs the
most developing out of the top four but
the reward is also the biggest because
of his size his light feet at that size
the way he man handles people in the run
game I saw some buzz out there that he's
not a finisher in the run game I think
you should go back and watch the rest of
the film because the guy most definitely
is and I had a good laugh at him pulling
a truck this weekend while everybody's
in quarantine so for the Bucs here I
don't think this is happening to happen
I don't think you'll get this lucky but
if you do you have to take Makai Becton
and upgrade that tackle spot if I was
them too I would give Jason Peters a
call right now and see what he wants
yeah I would as well I think the
Buccaneers are another team that you're
at least upgrading one of those tackle
spots I've routinely had them going
Andrew Thomas or even reaching a little
bit for a Josh Jones a coaching overall
yes at 15 the Denver Bryce I have one
with him at about Makai Becton you said
he was pulling a truck during quarantine
not impressed I'll be more impressed
when I see a truck pull Makai Becton
right I think we should expect it at
this point is massive bigger than a Ford
Ranger ya know without a doubt all right
number 15 the Denver Broncos we a lot of
the times we have Henry rugs fall to
this spot but again this is of what we
would do mock drafts of rugs lamb and
Judy are off the board I will still take
Justin Jefferson here I think he would
pair very very well with Courtland
Sutton we've talked so much about hey
help drew lockout I don't personally
value any of the left tackles at 15
overall with the the run on them but we
had here so I think if you can't protect
him a little bit better an upgrade over
Garrett bulls who had to be the most
penalized left tackle in football last
year if you can't upgrade there let's
upgrade in the passing game to give him
some weapons to go with Courtland Sutton
to go a Melvin Gordon to go and no a fan
I think Justin Jefferson's quickness is
route running what he does after the
catch would be very very nice in Denver
and I'm up with 16 overall I think a lot
of people are gonna hate this pick but I
don't care this is what I would do the
Atlanta Falcons just signed Todd Gurley
I don't think Todd Gurley can carry the
load by himself I I think this is a
two-year deal and then after that I
think the
they're probably gonna move on like the
Rams did so it's 16 overall the deandre
Swift sitting right there
there's a lot of questions about these
two Georgia backs and can they carry the
load who cares
get them both take DeAndre Swift let
them split carries let DeAndre Swift
develop in and the power run game and
get a good mentor for Todd Gurley for
the next two years and then after that I
think DeAndre Swift's the best running
back in this class I really love what
he's able to do in the passing game I
think that he probably needs to add a
little weight a little bulk to a size
but you're getting a Pro Bowl level
running back here after you upgraded
your offensive line last year and I'm
sorry I'm just not sold on the Todd
Gurley signing I will say this as of
Monday morning at 9:15
the Falcons actually haven't announced
that signing so it might who knows if
it's actually even happened it's weird
right now right because like you can
agree to things and it's not official
until there's a physical so they could
be waiting but the Falcons actually
haven't announced the Todd Gurley
signing hmmm something to think about so
I'm gonna think about all right let's
take a break we come back Conners on the
clock for the Dallas Cowboys at 17
overall number 17 the Dallas Cowboys and
I'm going with Javon Kinlaw here guys I
still think Dallas needs a lot up front
on that defensive line obviously they
lose Robert Quinn on the edge so you can
consider Kayla von chase on here but I
still think they need an interior
wrecker and I think what Kinlaw stealing
in this spot he'd just be a phenomenal
player for them I love Derrick brown I'm
Derrick brown great it higher than
Kinlaw but I think Kinlaw still has a
chance to end up being the better player
just with the trajectory he's on at the
college level being a late bloomer
he's somebody that would a little
coaching in Dallas can be a guy that you
know just destroys the game up front
against the run and against the pass
with how big and how athletic he is yeah
it's easy to look at Kinlaw and say Lee
in this in this defense he would be
phenomenal absolutely phenomenal number
18 the Miami Dolphins Connor gave them
Jedrek wills at pick number five overall
a lot of people's okay we'll give him a
quarterback here Matt no I will not good
day I'm gonna give them a pass rusher I
know they've added a ton of like savvy
veteran dudes who are just you know
they're gonna be good players but not
great players in this defense you still
need I think someone who can be that you
know ass-kicking
pass rusher Caleb on chase sounds on the
board he's my number nine overall player
if I'm the Dolphins this is my pick you
still have 26 you still have two
second-round picks I believe they have
to first next year you have resources to
get a quarterback and I am firmly of the
opinion that if they're if you're on the
board and there's not a quarterback that
you like don't draft one don't take ej
manuel just because you need a
quarterback you know don't we and the
Dolphins did this once Ryan Tannehill
has turned it around but they took a
quarterback just because they needed one
and it didn't work
don't do that wait it's better to be bad
for another year than to miss on a
quarterback that's what what happened if
the Dolphins reached for a Herbert or
Jordan love at the spot yeah and I think
you already have Fitzpatrick in house
III with you I wouldn't take one of the
quarterbacks here luckily I'm not
picking for them I'm picking for the Las
Vegas Raiders at 19 overall Matt you
gave them Henry rugs to start off with
and again what I would do is what we're
kind of hearing with mock drafts a lot
too I'm gonna give him Patrick Queen at
linebacker I think that he could play
off all linebacker positions I think
after a couple years in the league he
develops and he's gonna be a true ass
kicker like you say that middle
linebacker his speed place everywhere
his aggressiveness his coverage ability
I really like Patrick Queen I think
maybe he can start to slow down some of
these tight ends and some of these
running backs out of the backfield that
the AFC West has 20 Jacksonville Jaguars
they got CJ Henderson from Matt in the
first round at number nine overall their
second pick in the first round here
let's just rebuild the entire secondary
guys now you go with Antoine Winfield
jr. so you got a number one corner and
now a top safety that can pretty much
play every single role on the field he
can play in the box you can cover in the
slot it plays into deep so I think what
Winfield jr. you have a guy that takes
away the football and for Jacksonville
they've traded away a lot of players it
doesn't I don't feel good that they're
gonna make this work within Gok way
long-term but it'd be great if they can
keep them up front with these two guys
in the back so when you look at it for
Jacksonville they are rebuilding this
defense and with the way the board fell
these are just the best available
players to them number 21 the
Philadelphia Eagles is a popular spot
for Justin Jefferson in a regular what
we think will have a mock draft
what we would do Jefferson it's gone but
I'm still gonna go wide receiver and
maybe I'm just stubborn
I still like T Higgins I know the 40
time wasn't great at the pro day but I
like T Higgins I think he's one of the
best vertical receivers in this game and
something that's really missing for
Carson Wentz Stewart has a rocket like
this is a big armed quarterback he'd get
outside the pocket launch the ball down
the field he needs someone who's going
to be reliable not a Nelson angle or
bringing the ball down they need a big
year from JJ I say go Whiteside who did
nothing as a rookie they need it
healthier Sean Jeffery back but t
Higgins even though not the burner down
the field I think a lot of Eagles fans
would want just give Carson Wentz more
productivity at that position and
Higgins will do that
yeah and I'm up next with the Minnesota
Vikings
you just took T Higgins so now I'm kind
of in a panic here I want a receiver for
this team I traded away a damn good one
I need a new one I'm gonna go with
Denzel Mims out of Baylor I think that
he can come in and play across from Adam
Thielen and maybe you keep this offense
rolling you need another target like I
know you traded one but you need another
target in this offense to keep things
rolling the way that you had them
rolling with Minnesota and Denzel Mims
is a pretty complete wide receiver we're
seeing him do a lot of things at the
Senior Bowl I really like what he can do
and how he fits in this offense
23 the New England Patriots and I'm
going with Jordan love here guys the
Patriots are going into the season right
now with Brian Hoyer at quarterback
Jarrett stood him at quarterback it's
assumed that Stidham will take over that
job if they don't make a big addition in
the draft but with love falling to 23
not having to move up for him I think
this is the guy to develop if you're in
New England right now he has a huge arm
he can move really really well he does
not need to play from day one this is a
landing spot that makes so much sense
and if your New England
you're not giving anything to go up and
get him and Wow look at the way the
board broke I like Jordan love better
than Justin Herbert number one if I was
trying to develop a guy I see higher
impact traits in love's game so I think
New England is a team and the team after
them the Saints are another one those
teams can afford to draft and stash
Jordan love similar to the way the
Chiefs did with Patrick mahomes a couple
years ago and that's what I've done here
24 overall the New Orleans Saints we
have Justin Harbor falling
again this this won't happen but you
know what we would do mock Justin
Herbert still here and I am intrigued by
him as a girafft and stash player ID
should not see the field your one but
playing behind drew brees I know they
put the first round tinder in the
exclusive tag on Taysom Hill but I don't
believe at 30 years old with two knee
injuries and 13 passes thrown in his
career he's the guy long-term let's get
Justin Herbert in here let him learn
behind Drew Brees I think he could be a
fun fit in this offense that has Michael
Thomas has Alvin Kamara now has him
Manuel Sanders would open things up a
little bit Drew Brees
doesn't have the strongest arm but he is
one of the best deep ball throwers in
the NFL so Herbert's skill set actually
fits here pretty well in my opinion and
the number 25 the Minnesota Vikings
again just gave him Denzel Mims at 22
overall now I'm looking at the depth
chart I'm looking at the big board and
I'm saying what do we need I think they
could use another pass rusher to go
opposite of Hunter getting after the
quarterbacks was gonna be very important
especially when you get into the
playoffs and you're trying to beat drew
Brees again why not go out and get an
edge rusher that fits in this 4-3
defense I like the way he bent I like
his athletic ability I think he's the
number three edge guy in this class for
me and and after this I think the edge
class gets very weak so if I'm gonna
take one back into the first round I get
the third best one in this class and I'm
very happy about that 26 the Miami
Dolphins number five I gave them Jedrek
wills then Matt gave them an 18 Caleb on
chase on so they got a franchise tackle
up front
they got a do-it-all linebacker that's
really gonna rush the passer at the next
level and chase on at 26 year I'm going
with Jonathan Taylor and I know we've
picked running back for them before in
previous mock drafts but now you have
the offensive line or at least a piece
on the offensive line that you feel you
can run behind with this offense so for
the Dolphins I'm not playing the game of
reaching for a quarterback
I'm not taking Jake from Jacob Eason
here Jalen hurts I'm not doing that in
the spot I'm getting really good
football players for Brian Flores and
now Chan Gailey is back at offensive
coordinator to make this offense work
and I think if you're a Dolphins fan in
this situation you might be disappointed
you're coming out of this draft without
your franchise quarterback but your team
is getting a lot
better those are three huge pieces for
your franchise where maybe you do take a
one-year flyer on Cam Newton maybe you
do take a one-year flyer on Jameis
Winston if I was gonna do it I'm taking
the flyer on Cam Newton ten out of ten
times in that spot but this team guys
after free agency and after the first
round of our mock draft and having two
more second-round picks feels really
really improves on paper I would rather
have jaylen Hertz in the second round
then Jordan love or Justin Herbert 26
just for that specific team for that
team I would rather have three
first-round picks who are starters and
Jalen Hertz than two first-round picks
were starters and Justin Harbor and then
you try to fill in some of these gaps in
around two of the other positions number
27 the Seattle Seahawks as of right now
they have not resigned Jadeveon Clowney
I think pass rusher is a huge need even
if he does come back LJ Collier last
year's first-round pick has done nothing
they do have a couple good players in
the interior but neither one is it and
really an electric pass rusher I think
you can solve two of these problems with
one player in AJ up in Essen from Iowa
we've talked before a little bit about a
tweener
is he a D in is he a D tackle put him
somewhere where he can be both this is a
lot like how Michael Bennett was used in
this defense let him play both based on
assignment based on down in distance I
like epinasty Lin credibly productive
over the last two years in the big ten
yes he's a little bit big six foot six
probably around 280 we could see him
play it I think we could see him play at
265 I think we could see him play at 285
it's just what you want him to be but
the production and the technique are
absolutely there number 28 overall the
Baltimore Ravens they keep winning the
offseason here they still need a middle
linebacker and Kenneth Murray has fallen
to them I think this is a no-brainer I
think is if this happens in the real
draft well in history you would run the
card up to the podium I don't know what
the hell you do now you send a text
message and say we want Kenneth Murray
whatever you do you take Kenneth Murray
who fits in this defense and can come be
an alpha now I mean like Ray Lewis used
to lead this defense I think Kenneth
Murray is another guy who's going to
come in and very early on take over that
defense and lead any defense that he's
on 29 the Tennessee Titan
here listen I know when they lost Jack
Conklin they were prepared they have
Dennis daily they feel like he could
play right tackle his guarantees are
mostly in the first year that contract
29 I'm gonna do a little bit of a reach
here because I like the player I'm going
with Isaiah Wilson he is strictly a
right tackle if you listen to this
podcast you know that Isaiah Wilson is
built like a house if Makai Becton was
not in this class everybody would talk
about how huge Isaiah Wilson is and he
is an absolute unit of a run blocker on
the right side so when I look at
Tennessee in this spot you lost Jack
Conklin and this is a downgrade and past
protection but I think Isaiah Wilson
would be at least just as good as
Conklin was as a run blocker that's how
powerful this guy where if is where if
you keep it simple for him and if you if
you don't feel good about him starting
for day one and you want him to be the
swing tackle that's fine because you
have Dennis Daley there but Isaiah
Wilson is a perfect scheme fit with this
Tennessee offense at 30 the Green Bay
Packers I'm this is not the biggest need
but we have depleted the wide receiver
core there's not a tight end I feel like
that I would draft a 30 overall so I'm
gonna look to the future and go
offensive tackle this is a team that is
getting a little bit older after tackle
since we've seen Brian Bulaga already
leave Josh Jones from Houston is gonna
be my guy he's an athlete who I actually
think could play right tackle primarily
played left at Houston I think you play
right tackle just fine so I'm doing some
of the Senior Bowl but he's an athlete
with an incredibly high ceiling he does
play nasty he can be a finisher and yes
he is a little bit roll but I think we
saw throughout the process what we were
able to see of the process at least a
player who continued to get better with
good coaching so I'm high on Josh Jones
I think he's 32 or 33 on my boards so a
pretty good value for the Packers here
but also keeping this team young as they
move into the the twilight of Aaron
Rodgers career and I think he could be a
tackle like Connor said like a swing
tackle for a year or two and then he
probably replaces that left tackle and
as your starter there for a while number
31 overall the San Francisco 49ers
already gave him receiver I'm gonna go
corner here I'm gonna go Jeff Gladney I
like his game
I like how physical he is he doesn't let
these big receivers bully him I mean we
saw him shut down the receiver from Iowa
State
he's just very good at jumping routes
and
with quickness he can click and close he
does everything that you want out of a
corner I think if he were six foot tall
instead of the 510 we're talking about
him is probably a top 15 overall pick
but he's just lacks a little bit of
length in his game there's nothing that
he can do about that
other than that it looks pretty damn
good so I think the 49ers be very happy
to get him yet here at 31 overall yeah I
love that pick for their secondary I
think it's a perfect fit 32 the final
pick of our round one mock draft today
your Kansas City Chiefs here Melo get
Cesar Ruiz and he could play all three
spots on the interior offensive line I
think it's an area Kansas City really
needs to I don't want to say hit the
panic button on but more so stay ahead
of the curve here you have Pat mahomes
keep the guy protected and with Ruiz
he's not only good in pass protection
but they get this guy moving in the run
game so for this this is a plug and play
starter from day one whatever spot you
feel you need the most help at probably
Center in my eyes feel free to disagree
here guys but I think Ruiz at 32 is it's
just a perfect perfect pick here for the
Chiefs that he fell this far yeah I love
that pick for the Chiefs because I do
think you have to protect your asset and
in Patrick mahomes you didn't do it last
year
go get the best center in the draft and
if Cesar Ruiz is there I do hope the
Chiefs taking